y avait-il la pleine lune le jour de la
naissance d'antoine pinay la thèse de
doctorat de valérie bonnet ne le dit pas
mais l'étudiante en médecine stéphanoise
a savamment étudié les incidences de la
lune sur les naissances des enfants
mythe ou réalité
reportage un jour de pleine lune dans
une maternité quel rapport entre la lune
et ses quartiers ce petit bout d'homme
qui vient tout juste d'ouvrir les yeux
est ce que comme le dit la légende les
phases de la lune ont une influence
directe sur les accouchements
on a trouvé nos plans d'ailleurs de
pleine lune
ils avaient plus accouchement ou et que
les autres jours je sais pas où ces
décès des vieux nick temps ça doit
certainement avoir une raison et je
pense que c'est probable je pensais ça
pourrait jouer un rôle comme la lune
joue un rôle sur les marées sont pour et
les bébés pour avoir une petite marie
intérieur ça serait marrant
selon les lieux et les époques les
influences qu'on lui attribue ne sont
pas toujours les mêmes
dans certaines régions on pense que la
pleine lune provoque les accouchements
dans d'autres c'est le premier quartier
pour d'autres encore ce sont les
changements de lune pour mettre les
choses au clair dans le cadre d'une
thèse de médecine
valérie bonnet a minutieusement étudiées
3684 de l'essence spontanée moi j'ai pas
réussi à démontrer qu'il y avait une
influence du cycle lunaire sur le
déclenchement des accouchements
spontanée mais donc j'ai pas retrouvé de
relations directes mais par contre on
peut pas affirmer non plus qu'il y en a
pas parce que la répartition des
naissances ne paraît pas complètement
sur les lois du hasard
on peut alors imaginer que le facteur
psychologique joue un rôle important
comme si les mamans voulait parfois
donné raison à la légende
valérie elle devrait accoucher à la
prochaine pleine lune
mais ce sera un pur hasard
et